[موسيقى]
وضعت احذيه الاطفال هذه بشكل رمزي امام
هذا النصب النصب الذي كتب عليه اسماء طلاب
المدارس الداخليه من السكان الاصليين
فمنهم من ماتوا داخل المدارس بسبب الامراض
او التعنيف ومن هم من ماتوا بعد ان خرجوا
من المدارس بسبب الذكريات المؤلمه
[موسيقى]
وهو
صغير
عندما عادوا من المدارس الداخليه ارسلوهم
مباشره للالتحاق بالجيش وشاركوا في
الحربين العالميتين لم يبقوا سوا عام واحد
في المحميات ثم اخذوا اغلبهم الى الحرب
ليقتلوا او يموتوا بعد عودتهم
[موسيقى]
هل تتذكرين اي قصه من القصص التي كان
يرويها لك اجدادك عن المدارس الداخليه في
كندا
لم يتحدث كثيرا عن ما حدث لهم في المدارس
الداخليه اعتقد انهم كانوا يخافون الحديث
عنها اعتقدوا انهم يخبئون ذلك بداخلهم
ودائما كانوا يقولون لا تتحدث عن هذه
الايام اننا اناس اقوياء ويجب ان ندير
انفسنا اعتقد ان هذا احد الاسباب التي لم
تجعلهم يتحدثون عن تفاصيلهم ما حدث لهم
لكننا مازلنا نسمع بعض القصص من هنا وهناك
مجتمعنا معروف بتناول المخدرات والكحول
وذلك بسبب كابتن مشاعرهم جدي كان واحدا
منهم وتوفي في عمر 47 عاما بسبب المخدرات
عربي عربي
درسنا وبصراحه اتذكر انه في الستينيات لم
يسمح لنا باكمال دراستنا بحسب القانون
الهنديه